now it just amazes me how many people especially
in the medical profession just treat constipation
as a symptom they do not look at the whole picture
they might just tell you it's just a lack of fiber
just take more fiber metamucil whatever and
fiber will stimulate the colon which will help
you evacuate and it's hydrating so just take some
fiber that's it but constipation is the effect of
incomplete digestion anywhere in your digestive
tract i mean it could be a lack of stomach acid
because stomach acid helps you break down
protein if you're not breaking down protein
that can end up as undigested protein
then you have the pancreas which produces
all these enzymes and enzymes really work in
the small intestine you have like 20 feet of
of tubing called the small intestine which by
the way your small intestine the little villi
actually make enzymes and also the pancreas
releases enzymes in the small intestine and that's
where 90 of all your digestion occurs and so that
doesn't occur correctly guess what undigested
food both undigested carbohydrates undigested
fats undigested protein and it ends up as a
constipation situation then you have the liver
that makes bile salts and it's stored by the
gallbladder and that's released into the small
intestine and bile salts are the detergent that
helps break down fat to a certain level where
the enzymes in the pancreas can then take over
and fully digest the fats but the thing
about bile is bile lubricates the colon
bile hydrates the colon and so if you're deficient
in bile you could very easily get constipation
now the problem with getting too much bile as
you end up with diarrhea so you just need just
the right amount not too much not too little so
after all this food is digested from the acid
from the enzymes from the bile it finally ends
up into the large intestine called the colon
this is where your friendly microbes both friendly
bacteria and friendly yeast take over and they
start to finalize this digestive process they
will take things that you can't digest like fiber
and break those down they also help reabsorb the
water as well and so if you have constipation it
could be that you need more stomach acid you
need bile salts you need enzymes or you need a
good probiotic 16 of americans have constipation
and 30 of americans over 60 have constipation so
it's a big deal and i really want you to take
a look at the whole digestive process if you
personally have constipation rather than
just one thing like adding more fiber
and so you can get a clue on the cause of
constipation and what you need to do based on
when it started so let's say you started after
an antibiotic well guess what you need probiotics
and by the way anytime you're on an antibiotic
you should automatically take probiotics at the
same time don't wait till you're done take it
at the same time you take antibiotics now let's
say for example you develop constipation when you
took an antacid well then just put back the acid
betaine hydrochloride or let's say you started
taking medications that have a side effect of
constipation well get with your doctor and find
some alternative that doesn't have a side effect
of constipation or let's say you had a history of
eating a lot of cooked foods a lot of processed
foods and no raw foods that have enzymes well
then start eating raw foods like raw vegetables
or let's say there wasn't an actual time that
it started but you don't like vegetables you
don't consume a lot of vegetables an average
american consumes like a cup and a half of
vegetables well guess what we need that fiber for
our microbes to actually live off of we also need
the potassium and magnesium in those vegetables
to help the pumping action of your colon in fact
when you add more potassium magnesium that does
help the bowels work correctly and a lot of times
people instead of consuming vegetables they might
take epsom salts right which creates a laxative
effect and then they get diarrhea also too many
high carbohydrates can interfere with the nervous
system that controls this whole process it's
called the enteric part of the autonomic nervous
system so if that's the case you need something
called benfotamine which is a type of b vitamin
that actually will help support that issue also
frequent eating it's the cramming of all this food
down this pipe never letting the body properly
digest and go through its cycle it takes 36 hours
for food to be completely processed through
your entire digestive tract so if we're eating
so frequently all the time we never get a
chance for your system to really clean out
another point is stress stress activates
the fly to fight mechanism which inhibits
the nervous system that controls the digestion
which is called the parasympathetic nervous system
so many many times you don't need to change
the diet you just need to fully relax you need
to improve the parasympathetic nervous system
and i put a link down below how you should do
that reducing your stress greatly improves your
digestion and so a couple other tips fermented
foods are good increasing your veggies increasing
more fat which will stimulate bile production
because if you're on a low fat diet that can
be a reason why you don't have enough bile
and if you're in the bile things
dry up and you get constipation
also lowering your carbs already mentioned that
and then doing intermittent fasting is very very
important all right thanks for watching hey before
you go real quick i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof your immune system it's a free
course i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today